The title of Thomas Piketty's book
is Capital in the 21st Century.
It's probably worth having a conversation
about what capital is.
If you're going to produce anything,
you need some input,
you need some factors for that production.
You'd put them together.
Let's say that you are a farm.
Your output is food.
What are your inputs going to be?
This is a farm right over here.
Let me a draw a little circle here.
Farm and your output is food.
What are your inputs going to be?
You're going to need some land.
You're going to need some water.
You're going to need some equipment.
And you are going to need some seeds
and animals so, I'll just put generally here, supplies.
And of course, you're going to need people to
put all these things together
and essentially work the land,
to plow the soil and plant the seeds
and harvest the crops
and manage the whole operations.
You're going to need labor as well.
You take all of these factors of production together.
They essentially represent a farm
that is going to output food.
When people talk about capital
as a factor of production,
sometimes they talk about it in a fairly narrow way.
They'll separate things like land and resources
or something separate and they'll say capital
is hey, that's your equipment and your supplies.
When people talk in more general terms,
especially, in the focus of this book
when there are people talking about labor versus capital.
Capital when we just group things
in only those two categories
in that context, capital would essentially represent
pretty much everything else.
This right over here would be capital
and one way to think about capital
is the things that you could maybe you,
they are assets that you have
that can be valued that will give you future benefit.
You can buy and sell those assets
and we could think about other businesses here.
Other things that are trying to produce something.
Let's say you have a mine.
This is the operation
and it's going to produce,
let's just say it's a goldmine.
It's going to produce gold.
What are the inputs that you would need there?
You're clearly gonna need some labor.
You're gonna need the miners and the people
who would manage the operation of the goldmine
but that's not all you need.
You also need energy
maybe to operate your equipment
and I actually, I will put energy in here too.
Some of which comes from the sun
but some of which you might have to purchase
or have somehow
and then you would also need equipment.
And you would need supplies.
I mean we could consider energy as supply
if you like or you use supply of energy
but you also might need tires or something like that.
You might need food in order to
provide for the labor.
Who knows what else you might need in your mine?
And you also would need, of course, land.
You need access to land to actually mine.
Here, if we're thinking very broad terms,
you could view all of this as the capital
and of course, you have your labor
and you put your labor and your capital together
and you produce the gold.
Another idea that you will hear in life a lot
but obviously, in a book about capital,
this will come up a lot,
it's the idea of return on capital.
This is just a measure of giving a value of capital
that you've employed,
how much income are you getting for that capital.
For example, let's say this farm.
The total value of this capital,
let's just say it is,
I don't know, I'll make up a number here.
Let's just say it is $1 million.
$1 million is the total value of the land
and maybe you have access to your own lake
and the equipment and the supplies.
It's $1 million of capital.
The value of that capital is $1 million.
Let's say that the income of the farm
after you pay the labor.
Actually, let's just do this in a little broader term.
Let's say the food's value,
the food that's produced has a value of $100,000
in the market.
Now, out of that $100,000, you obviously had
to pay your labor.
Let's say that $50,000 of it, goes to the labor.
And then we're saying this is in a given year.
You use the capital of the labor,
You produce $100,000 worth of food.
$50,000 goes to the labor was gonna
be returned on capital.
You have another 50,000 leftover for the capital
for the owners of the capital
whoever owned the farm.
The owners of the capital would get the other
$50,000.
Your return on capital is going to be $50,000
that's what the owner of the capital gets
and it's thee return on their investment
of $1 million.
And this is going to be the same thing
as 5 divided by 100
or it would be 5%.
You have a 5% return on capital.
You invest $1 million, you're going to get $50,000.
It was a 6% return on capital,
you invest $1 million.
You get $60,000.
Now, that we've thought about that a little bit,
let's actually at a pretty neat chart
from the book and once again, it's pretty neat.
If you look right over here
piketty.psc.ens.frcapital21c.
He has all the charts from his book,
which make for interesting analysis at minimum
and he's gathered all of this information.
This is pretty interesting.
There's capital and slavery in the United States.
And what's interesting about that is
when you study American history,
you talk a lot about slavery
but you don't realize that
in the time of slavery as abhorrent as it is
and was, people viewed slaves as capital,
not as laborer.
They view them as something that they could buy or sell
that they own and that would create future income
for them and this just gives us a sense
of kind of the breakdown of capital over history.
You see down, at least in the United States,
you see agricultural land.
In 1770, it was a reasonable percentage.
This is a value capital as a percentage
of national income.
The value of the land is a percentage
of national income was much higher than it is, today
and we see the other trend
that the other domestic capital has become
much more value.
Well, what is this other domestic capital?
This could be things like infrastructure.
It could be technology.
It could be mechanical technology.
Things like trains and cars and trucks and buses
or, and factories or it could be software.
It could be computers,
whatever else and as we see as we went through
the industrial revolution,
the value of other forms of technology became...
or other forms of capital other than land
became more and more important
for our economy and obviously, slavery ended
in the mid late 1860's and obviously, that went away
but it's just an interesting way to think
about macroeconomic trends in the United States.
Land in 1770 was a major factor of production
and still is obviously.
We still need land in order to produce things,
especially, agriculture.
Well, this is agriculture
and it's still a major part.
It's not like the land has disappeared.
It's just that the economy has grown
to be much more than just agriculture.
In 1770, agriculture was a big part
of our economy.
Now, agriculture is a much, much smaller
part of our economy.
This is just an interesting way
to think about, well, okay, this is all of the capital
and this both public and private capital included here.
Public capital would be something
that is owned by the public, by the government
while private capital would be something
that is owned by private individuals
or corporations or whatever else
but you see on average, you have had kind of a
a fairly constant give or take a little bit
that the total value of the capital
has been around four to five times
the value of the total productive output,
four to five times the value
of the total productive output of the country.